I think he's going to run I was thinking
about it over the weekend because almost
the opposite reasons why Trump is
running so Trump has a lot of enthusiasm
with voters people really they feel
connected to Trump they feel this
loyalty to Trump with Biden it's the
opposite so I think with Biden it's the
establishment who's very happy with his
performance they like having somebody
who's just kind of a puppet who they can
pull the strings you know he's not going
to fight back he's not going to give
them a hard time he really doesn't know
what's going on and so they like having
that person in there who they can boss
around now as you said the enthusiasm
from voters might not be there but the
establishment and and the swamp really
as far as Democrats go who are in charge
they don't care they know the voters
will vote for him I mean that's the big
difference here there's a difference
between lacking enthusiasm and people
not actually going out and voting for
you just because Democrats aren't
excited about him I don't think they're
going to not
vote for him